hey David I like most of Bernie's
policies but I don't like Bernie
everyone I know that has met him says
he's a dick okay I wonder who you know
that has met him I also don't want a
nearly 80 year old leading the
progressive movement he has to stop
saying he's a Democratic Socialist it'll
never work
does the progressive movement need a
rebrand your question implies a sort of
similar understanding to some of the
analysis I made after Super Tuesday and
what that analysis was included the
realization that something like Medicare
for all the left is is split on Medicare
for all you have people who simply don't
want it you have people who do want it
but not at the exclusion of being able
to keep private insurance that there's a
lot of different opinions about Medicare
for all on the left my belief is that
many elements 75 80 % of Medicare for
all
most of the left would come around to if
it was given to them by the right
candidate and framed in the right way
and not presented as what you have will
be taken away but rather this will be
created and you can choose to take
advantage of this or if you want to keep
paying for insurance you can do it but
we are going to fund this in the
following way as Bernie has pointed out
okay fine I don't think it's crazy to
say that when you hear it from a nearly
80 year old Democratic Socialist from
Brooklyn if you are a North Florida
Democrat you are more likely to be
repelled by it than to welcome it this
is not my view understand I don't care
about Bernie's identity and I'm doing
the best I can to look at the policies
but I understand that there are a lot of
people who would be in favor of 80
percent of Bernie's medicare-for-all
plan and his free college plan assuming
that it's the version that includes
trade school and so on and so right that
the policies themselves are certainly
more popular than it might appear from
the overwhelming way in which Joe Biden
has outperformed Bernie in the popular
vote in the Democratic primary
so yeah I completely understand what
you're saying now as far as whether the
progressive movement needs to rebrand
I'm less sure about that one of the
concerns I've expressed is when I see
people deifying politicians almost like
like gods like deities I don't care who
it is I think that that's a problem
right you have a movement in this
country it's probably about 60 or 70
percent of Trump supporters that see
Trump as a pseudo deity they see him
almost like a god he can do no wrong he
can shoot someone on Fifth Avenue
whatever I think that that's absolutely
terrible I've pointed out before there
are elements of this in the Democratic
Party as well we saw it I would say
anecdotally from the emails I got I had
to see supporters Andrew yang supporters
and Bernie supporters who really seem to
see the three respective candidates as
almost perfect beings as almost a they
are deifying them in some way and I
don't know if it's because I've met
enough of these politicians that I just
don't get sucked into the cult of
personality or whatever but these are
just people these are flawed people they
all have some good ideas and some ideas
that are not so good you can like nine
out of ten policies from one person and
you can still recognize maybe that 10th
out of 10 policy doesn't make sense or
doesn't that the numbers don't balance
or whatever the case may be and when I
see anyone deifying a candidate I get
concerned because I don't think that we
should be defying politicians at all
there's a very emotional reaction to
Bernie among some of his supporters that
reminds me of some of the emotional
reaction that we see with Donald Trump
now remember I support the vast majority
of Bernie's policies and we've been
supporting them on the program for a
while that doesn't mean that I see
Bernie as the be-all end-all in terms of
the progressive movement I think that
the way that the progressive movement
will succeed is not necessarily a
rebrand but it's number one you got to
stop the democratic socialist stuff I've
been talking about that for a very very
long time I know there's part of the
progressive movement that likes to say
socialism pulls better than it has in
decades
it still doesn't pull that well and it's
still not a good idea to be talking
about when the policies you're
advocating aren't actually democratic
socialist policies there's no
upside so whether it's a rebrand or
whether it's picking candidates that
maybe better relate to people
demographically or whatever the case me
is it AOC I don't know maybe maybe not I
don't I don't know does she call herself
a Democratic Socialist I'm not sure but
what you have to look at is in a way
it's crazy look at what the Tea Party
did in 2010 the Tea Party with terrible
policies that were genuinely bad for the
vast majority of the people that
supported Tea Party candidates built a
pseudo movement which was then
integrated into the Republican Party and
moved the entire party in that direction
you're not seeing that happen in the
same way with the progressive movement
and I don't know it pains me to see it
not happen I don't know if it's the
people I don't believe that it's the
policies I think the policies are good
it may be the framing or the language
around some of the policies I'm going to
be thinking about this a lot and talking
about it at once we get past the the
primary phase but I'd be curious to hear
from you for sure